Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Neuer Papst, neuer Kanzler steht jetzt wieder alles für die goldenen Zwanziger.
Jo, mit dem zweiten Wahlkanzler und dem dritten Wahlpapst könnte ich mir schöner
nicht vorstellen, die goldenen Zwanziger.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 523 vom 9.
Mai 2025 und alles ist wieder frisch besetzt und alles wieder auf Null und jetzt
kannst du wieder von vorne losgehen, ist doch schön, oder?
Ja. Toll.
Wird doch bestimmt alles total anders jetzt durch einen neuen Papst.
Durch einen neuen Kanzler.
Ich hatte gestern, da kam dann die Meldung weißer Rauch und dann habe ich mir
da den Livestream angeschaut.
Der Livestream wurde übertragen bei Spiegel Online und dann hatten sie außerdem einen Live-Blog.
Ich möchte da einmal das Level der Berichterstattung hier zitieren.
Francesco Colini, Auslandsresort des Spiegel, im Live-Blog, blockt also totale
Stadionstimmung hier gerade.
Also was das, da ist ja noch nicht mal ein Satz.
Totale Stadionstimmung hier gerade. Sobald eine Gruppe von Menschen auf den
Bildschirm, die am Petersplatz aufgestellt wurden, auftaucht,
gibt es tosenden Applaus.
Und nun kommt auch feierliche Musik aus den Lautsprechern.
What the fuck, Alter? Ich meine, dafür bezahle ich, dass da irgendein Stadion ...
Dinos, das sind Katholiken, verstehst du?
Die waren noch nie beim Fußball.
Nee, die müssen die ganze Zeit immer nur büßen und beichten und niederknien
und irgendwie den großen Gott und so weiter. Jetzt haben die allen mal was zu feiern.
Das ist die einzige Ausnahme, wo die dann mal sich verhalten dürfen,
ansatzweise wie ein Stadion.
Auch wenn es mehr so ein TSG Hoffenheim ist, als, muss ich nicht sagen, Pauli und Union.
Aber das muss man dann halt auch lassen. Man kommt ja so oft auch nicht vor.
Das ist ja nur irgendwie alle 20 Jahre.
Der neue Papst ist jetzt irgendwie 69, also der hält wahrscheinlich noch eine Weile.
Der hält, ja.
Ja, also ich finde das okay. Leben und leben lassen.
Ja, trotzdem, also totale Stadionstimmung hier gerade.
Also was ist das? Also sorry, ein bisschen Respekt, da wird gerade der Stellvertreter
Jesu auf Erden gekürt, ja, im dritten Anlauf.
Und der redet da von Stadionstimmung. Hat der überhaupt keinen Respekt hier
vor dem Stadthalter Trumps in Vatikanstadt.
Nein, stellt sich heraus, der hat zuletzt irgendwelche abschiebungskritischen Tweets retweetet.
Der Papst.
Bezug auf was? Bezug auf amerikanische Politik oder was?
Genau, da ging es um diese Abschiebedinger der Amerikaner. und da hat er irgendeinen
Retweet gemacht von jemandem, der sagt, habt ihr denn irgendwie überhaupt kein
Mitgefühl, was ihr da anrichtet?
Insofern könnte das sein, dass wir demnächst, dass demnächst der Vatikan mit
höheren Zöllen überzogen wird.
Das hast du jetzt davon.
200 Prozent auf Segen.
Oder noch schlimmer, Jenny Benz kommt noch mal vorbei. Das war's doch mit dem Papst.
Kommt, Benz, nochmal.
Kann ganz schnell gehen.
Also Segen wird richtig teuer für die Amis. Da müssen sie sich überlegen.
Ja, aber wir haben ja jetzt auch einen Kanzler, der kann dann auch mal vorbeikommen,
die Hand schütteln, das ist alles wieder schön.
Ja, Kanzler, zweiter Wahl. Übrigens will ich gar nicht lange diskutieren hier.
Erstmalig in der Geschichte der Bundesrepublik, dass ein Kanzler im ersten Anlauf
zu seiner formalen kurzen Bestätigung da scheitert.
Und gab es dann Leute, die das irgendwie natürlich in irgendeiner Weise gefeiert
haben, weil sie den Fritz Merz nicht mögen oder so.
Aber peinlich.
Es ist einfach nur peinlich. Weil das war ja nicht aus politischen Gründen,
dass da diese, waren das 16 oder 18 Leute offensichtlich...
Beim ersten Wahlgang gedacht haben, ich mache da mal einen kleinen Fleck der
Schande mit in diese Wahl und sich da offensichtlich ein paar zu viele Egos gekränkt waren.
Das waren ja keine Gewissenswahl-Dinge, die da stattgefunden haben.
Das waren einfach nur irgendwelche Leute, die nicht zufrieden waren mit den
Posten, die ihnen zugeschachert wurden.
Und das ist wirklich peinlich gewesen. Einfach nur peinlich.
Ja gut, weiß man nicht so ganz genau, was jetzt die einzelnen Gründe sind.
Da haben sie sich ja nicht dazu geäußert, das ist ja gar keine Wahl.
Kann man jetzt natürlich trefflich drüber spekulieren.
Ich meine, Merz ist ja letztlich schon, bevor er gewählt wurde,
mit den meisten seiner im Wahlkampf hinaus posaunenden Positionen quasi schon wieder fremdgegangen.
Und das ist wahrscheinlich ein Teil des Hintergrunds, wird man wahrscheinlich so nie erfahren.
Aber am Ende waren sie dann doch wieder alle auf Linie. Interessanter fand ich,
dass sie sich dann halt ob des parlamentarischen Prozederes ja mit den Linken zusammentun mussten,
um diesen Wahlgang schneller wieder einleiten zu können, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe.
Ja, die Linken, die Bösen.
Und als Belohnung kriegen sie jetzt eventuell den Unvereinbarkeitsbeschluss
der CDU wieder gestrichen.
Ich glaube, eine Sache könnte man noch kurz hervortun, weil ich das wirklich
erfrischend und stilvoll fand.
Die Ministerin Reiche, die ja in die Nachfolge von Robert Habeck tritt,
die in ihrer Antrittsrede einfach mal dessen,
die Arbeit dieses Hauses gewürdigt hat und insbesondere auch die des Ministers,
anerkannt hat, des scheidenden Ministers.
Das ist eine Geste, die, ja, es ist schon traurig, dass das jetzt inzwischen bemerkenswert ist.
Ja, und das sagt viel aus.
Hätte es auch irgendwie so einen Ausschnitt gesehen, dass der Markus Lanz mal
irgendein CDU-Vertreter da auch mal mit der Frage konfrontiert hat,
wie sie sich denn irgendwie den politischen Diskurs, ob sie jetzt irgendwie
vielleicht aufhören, andere Leute, die Kinderbücher geschrieben haben,
damit zu verunglimpfen.
Ja, weil das wäre, würde, glaube ich, diesen Vöglein da gut zu Gesicht stehen.
Ja, allen voran natürlich Markus Söder,
der diesen Stil vorantreibt und wirklich einfach ein absolut unangenehmer Zeitgenosse ist,
der durch diese Äußerung und diese Art des Umgangs keinen guten Beitrag zur
politischen Kultur des Landes leistet.
Und ja, eigentlich auch einfach zurück in die Kneipe gehört,
wo sie den irgendwann mal rausgeholt haben.
Aber ja, also wäre toll, wenn diese menschliche Größe irgendwo innerhalb der
Union auch wieder verfängt,
die da Frau Reiche gezeigt hat.
Da bin ich ja gespannt, ob sie diese Größe haben. Gut zu Gesicht würde es Ihnen tatsächlich stehen.
Ja, also wir werden es hier live berichten.
Wir werden es hier live mit kommentaren.
Wir machen dann einen Live-Blog dazu.
Wir machen einen Live-Blog.
Stadionstimmung im Parlament.
Dritte Halbzeit.
Geht richtig ab hier.
Das BMJ hatte vor, ich glaube, etwas über einem Jahr die Überwachungsgesamtrechnung
in Auftrag gegeben, das Bundesministerium der Justiz.
Und das ist eine Forderung, die auch schon, ich glaube, die habe ich schon,
also ich weiß gar nicht, wie alt die ist, ich glaube, da habe ich mit,
also bestimmt weit über zehn Jahre, eher in Richtung 20 Jahre,
dass so gesagt wurde, könnte nicht mal jemand hingehen,
Und irgendwie mal systematisch erfassen, wie viel Überwachung und Durchdringung
der Lebensbereiche durch Überwachung in der Bundesrepublik Deutschland gerade schon so stattfindet.
Und der Auftrag daran war erteilt worden an das Max-Planck-Institut zur Erforschung
von Kriminalität, Sicherheit und Recht.
Und die sollten quasi überhaupt mal prüfen, ob und wie sich denn so etwas berechnen
lässt. Ja, das ist ja jetzt also relativ klar, dass das nicht irgendwie auf
einen Bierdeckel mehr passt.
Und das wurde also jetzt in dieser Überwachungsgesamtrechnung wurden dann mal
alle Befugnisse aufgelistet, analysiert und bewertet. Also wie zielgenau sind sie?
Erfassen sie viele weitere Personen mit oder nicht?
Wie oft werden sie angewendet? Wie stark sind sie unter Kontrolle?
Wie hoch sind die Hürden, das zu machen? Was ist so die Überwachung,
der eine deutsche Bundesbürgerin ausgesetzt ist?
Und das war wirklich sehr faszinierend, dass das da überhaupt mal jemand versucht zu ermitteln.
Da haben sie gesagt, okay, dann gibt es irgendwie so einen Intensitätswert,
dann gibt es einen Mitigationswert, der das wieder abspricht.
Dadurch entsteht der normative Eingriffswert und dann haben sie Gewichtungen
gegeben. Richtig schön.
Und 52 Seiten, Tabellen und so weiter, wo halt mal jemand überhaupt versucht,
dieses vorher nicht Erfasste in irgendeiner Weise einem Framework zu unterziehen und zu messen.
Und dann gibt es natürlich unterschiedliche Befugniskategorien und die haben
dann diese Intensitätswerte, Mitigationswerte und Befugniswerte und so weiter
und so fort. Am Ende kommt raus 42.
Nein, kommt natürlich nicht.
Ich finde eher interessant, was so das Fazit ist, weil das tatsächlich irgendwie
über hunderte Seiten irgendwas oder über viele Seiten irgendetwas tabelliert, ja,
aber, und das waren gar nicht 52 Seiten, sondern viel mehr, ich wollte eigentlich
jetzt zu dem Fazit kommen.
Zusammenfassung und Ausblick. Wesentliche Ergebnisse, zu denen Sie dann auf Seite 106 kommen.
Die Gesamtheit der sicherheitsrechtlichen Befugnisnormen hat ein sehr hohes Komplexitätsniveau.
Und zwar gibt es 3.228 Befugnisse und Befugnisvarianten, auf denen die Sicherheitsbehörden
Überwachungsmaßnahmen anordnen und durchführen können.
Und das sei natürlich nur noch schwer zu überblicken. Deswegen wollte man ja
auch mal so eine Überwachungsgesamtrechnung haben.
3.800?
3.228 Befugnisse und Befugnisvarianten.
Können wir die jetzt alle mal aufzählen?
Lassen wir mal Ja.
Dann sagen Sie, die Analyse des normativen Überwachungsniveaus hat ergeben,
dass sich die Eingriffsintensität der großen Mehrzahl der untersuchten Befugnisse
durchweg in einem breiten, mittleren, schwere Bereich bewegen.
Das tatsächlich ausgefüllte Spektrum verschiedener Intensitätsstufen ist gleichwohl beachtlich.
Befugnisse mit einem sehr niedrigen Intensitätswert werden aber ebenso wenig
identifiziert wie Befugnisse mit dezidiert hohen Werten, wurden aber ebenso wenig identifiziert.
Dies kann als Bestätigung der These von der unitarisierenden Wirkung der verfassungsgerichtlichen
Kontrolle der Gesetzgebung gewährten. Ich habe keine Ahnung,
was dieser Satz bedeutet hat. Ich habe den jetzt mal wiedergegeben.
Die Zuordnung der differenzierten durch eine vielzahlvolle Parameter definierenden
Intensitäts- und Mitigationswerte hat einen sehr hohen Differenzierungsgrad
der einzelnen gesetzlichen Regelungen und Regelungsvarianten zutage gefördert.
Auch ein und dieselbe Befugnis wie etwa die Online-Durchsuchung ist in den verschiedenen
Gesetzen zum Teil so unterschiedlich normiert, dass sie bei der Bewertung deutlich
variierende Kennwerte erreicht.
Also mit anderen Worten, das ist ein ziemlich großes Kuddelmuddel und es gibt
natürlich da auch eine ganze Menge Datenlücken,
weil sie, und so fasst das zum Beispiel Falk Steiner, der Journalist, zusammen.
Die Anzahl der Maßnahmen, die für eine Überwachungsgesamtrechnung als einschlägig
gelten müssten, ist in Bayern und Rheinland-Pfalz im Ländervergleich besonders
hoch, in Berlin besonders niedrig.
Das sagt aber wiederum nichts über die tatsächliche Eingriffsqualität aus, laut den Autoren.
Denn in Bayern etwa sind diese regelmäßig mit hohen Regelungsstandards versehen,
was die Intensität wieder verringert.
Also soll heißen, vielleicht gibt es mehr Befugnisse in Bayern,
die haben aber dann wiederum, sind konkreter geregelt, was die in ihrer Überwachungsintensität
vielleicht wieder mindert.
Wer jemals in Bayern mit nicht der eine von fünf anerkannten Frisuren aus einem
Zug gestiegen ist und sofort einer Bundespolizeikontrolle anheim gefallen ist,
hat vielleicht einen etwas anderen Eindruck,
was die Intensitätsschwellen in Bayern angeht, aber okay, wir verstehen das.
Haben Sie jetzt mal gemacht, dann sagen Sie zum Beispiel auch irgendwie,
Fluggastdaten sind enorm in Ihrer Überwachungsintensität.
Als häufigsten Fall staatlicher Eingriffe betrachten die Studienautoren die
Fluggastdaten, ich zitiere wieder Falk Steiner, die an das Bundeskriminalamt gehen.
Mehr als 424 Millionen Mal wurden die 2020 an die Wiesbadener Bundesbehörde
von den Fluggesellschaften übermittelt.
424 Millionen Mal in einem Jahr haben die die Fluggastdaten abgegriffen.
Eine nahezu lückenlose Erfassung aller Flugreisenden, die nun auch auf Vorrat erfolgt.
Wow.
Wir haben das relativ, also die PNR Passenger Name Records Erfassung haben wir
so ein bisschen, also haben wir immer mal wieder behandelt im Logbuch,
aber das war jetzt nicht eines unserer Kernthemen.
Ja, stellt sich raus, ist einer der Überwachungstreiber.
Kurz mal nachgerechnet sind 13,5 Abfragen pro Sekunde.
Ja, da muss ein Oberstudienkommissar ganz schön schnell F5 drücken.
Da könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass sie sich dann ein Skript geschrieben haben. Nee, eine BAT-Datei.
PNR.BAT.
Ein Excel-Makro oder sowas.
Ist dir eigentlich jemals Zynismus vorgeworfen worden?
Nein. Hamburg ist Hauptstadt der Telekommunikationsüberwachung.
Telekommunikationsüberwachung?
Die Behörden in Bayern nutzen etwa besonders häufig die Abfrage von Telekommunikationsverkehrsdaten.
In Thüringen findet diese am seltensten statt.
Im Bevölkerungsreich im Bundesland
Nordrhein-Westfalen wiederum ist die Telekommunikationsüberwachung
vergleichsweise selten der Fall, im kleinen Hamburg am häufigsten.
Also wer viel telefoniert.
Telefoniert wird es in NRW.
Aber Problem ist, von Hamburg müsstest du auf jeden Fall mit dem Zug fahren.
Wenn du fliegst, landest du wieder bei BKA.
Aber ich weiß gar nicht, ob man Hamburg-Düsseldorf fliegen kann. Ist ja eher ein Sprung.
Gut, jetzt die Frage, was machen wir damit?
Naja, Falk schließt mit den Worten, ob der künftige Bundesinnenminister Alexander
Dobrindt von der CSU, also der, der jetzt erstmal wieder meinte,
er müsste mehr Grenzkontrollen oder sowas machen,
das Projekt weiterverfolgen will, ist bislang nicht bekannt.
Im neuen Koalitionsvertrag steht da natürlich nichts von drin.
Das wird jetzt eh ganz lustig werden. Nachdem Merz ja im Prinzip schon,
bevor er dann das zweite Mal endlich gewählt wurde,
nahezu alle seine Positionen abgeräumt hat, ist glaube ich jetzt Dobrindt dann
der Erste nach offizieller Inbetriebnahme dieser Region, der so die ersten Rückschritte machen soll.
Man merkt ja schon so aus Polen und so weiter, Leute, denkt gar nicht erst drüber nach.
Das gibt jetzt echt Ärger. Und in Zeiten des...
Der Notwendigkeit des Zusammenrückens von Europa, mit solchen Maßnahmen zu kommen,
ist halt irgendwie vollkommen gaga.
Zeigt aber leider nur wieder, dass die CDU da immer noch nicht den Arsch in
der Hose hat, einfach mal eine klare Politik zu fahren,
die vielleicht Dinge verbessert, sondern stattdessen halt immer wieder mit diesen
Bestrafungsmaßnahmen kommt mit, jetzt müssen wir hier mal den Rechten die Themen vom Tisch nehmen.
Und wo das dann endet.
Wissen wir ja alle.
Übrigens Grenzkontrollen. Ich bin kürzlich mal bei Frankfurt-Oder über die Grenze
gefahren nach Polen. Beziehungsweise in die andere Richtung.
Also in die eine Richtung war gar kein Problem, nach Polen kommst du.
Aber von Polen zurück nach Frankfurt-Oder über die Autobahn.
Da verjüngen die dann, dann haben die irgendwie so ein großes Zelt aufgebaut
für ihre Polizeikontrollen und dort entsteht dann da ein Stau.
Und da gibt es ein sehr faszinierendes Phänomen, was da stattfindet,
wo ich erst dachte, ach schau, guck, hier werfen die alles aus dem Fenster.
Also dieser Stau hält sich da offenbar so lang und es hat sich irgendwie so
eingebürgert, dass die Leute ihren ganzen Müll aus dem Auto werfen.
Und da hast du so eine Autobahn voll liegen mit so Müll.
Ja. Hast du mal reingeguckt? Hast du mal angehalten und geschaut, was da so dabei ist?
Na, ich dachte mir, was auch immer ich da finde, kann ich ja eh jetzt nicht
durch diese Krippe-Krolle bringen.
Nee, also ich dachte erst, naja, aber ich weiß auch nicht, was man,
also aus Polen bringt es halt, glaube ich, hauptsächlich Zigaretten und Schnaps
mit und einen vollen Tank, ja.
Und die, also Schnaps war da wenig, Zigaretten brauche ich nicht.
Ich habe noch geguckt, ob es andere Sachen, aber es sah ehrlich gesagt eher nach Müll aus.
Und dann, also völliger Quatsch, diese Verjüngung und dann musst du da an so
ein Grimmig, so ein Polizist, der dann so guckt.
Und dann, ja.
Also Grenzkontrollen sind halt keine Lösung in einem Schengen-System.
Ich meine, Wir wollen ja Europa als gesamten Bereich wahrnehmen und auch entsprechend
halten und das ist ja dann auch genau das, was die positiven Aspekte mit sich
bringt für die Wirtschaft.
Und wenn du dann halt Trucks sinnloserweise stundenlang da stehen lässt,
das erhöht einfach nur die Kosten für alle und bringt am Ende halt gar nichts.
Weil die winken dann in dieser Verjüngung 99,9 Prozent aller Fahrzeuge ohnehin durch.
Ich würde denken, sehr, sehr viel mehr als 99,9.
Prozent. Ja, wahrscheinlich kannst du nochmal zwei, drei, neun anhängen, genau.
Also ja, totaler Quatsch. Aber dann hat Dorin sich auch noch überlegt,
dass er jetzt dann da an der Stelle direkt Asylbewerberinnen abweisen möchte,
was natürlich nicht geht. Aber ja, hei, hei, hei, hei.
Kommen wir mal zu einer guten Nachricht Oh.
Vor vielen Jahren von uns schon berichtet, vor sechs Jahren von uns schon berichtet,
es gab damals von der NSO-Group einen Angriff über den Messenger WhatsApp mit
dem Ziel, Nutzerinnen mit dem Stadioner Pegasus zu infizieren.
Und zwar 1400 Mal ist das passiert und ich erinnere mich nicht mehr ganz genau an die Schwachstelle,
aber es war irgendwie ein Sprachanruf,
war also eine Schwachstelle irgendwie darin, wie WhatsApp Sprachanrufe gehandelt hat.
Konntest du wahrscheinlich irgendein kaputtes RDP oder sonst was Paket hinschicken
und dann dadurch das Gerät infizieren und Meta hat das irgendwie festgestellt,
analysiert und dann geklagt gegen die NSO Group und hat auch dabei Recht bekommen
und zwar im Dezember 2024.
Es blieb aber die Strafe offen und jetzt wurde von einer Jury in Kalifornien entschieden,
die NSO Group soll 167 Millionen US-Dollar Strafe an Meta zahlen,
sowie eine halbe Million US-Dollar als Schadensersatz.
Also an die betroffenen Personen dann?
Ja, mit dem Schadensersatz verstehe ich auch nicht. Ich hätte lieber den Betroffenen
das gegeben. Aber ja, okay. Interessant.
Natürlich wird die NSO-Gruppe das nicht unbedingt auf sich sitzen lassen.
Und ich vermute, dass sie irgendwie gegen sind, dass sie irgendwie noch was
dagegen versuchen werden zu tun. Aber im Moment sieht das erstmal so aus.
Außerdem will Facebook erreichen, dass sie eine gerichtliche Verfügung bekommen,
dass NSO das auch nie wieder darf.
Ja, das ist auf jeden Fall ein ganz schöner...
Also ich meine, wenn zwei sich streiten, freut sich der Dritte.
Es wäre natürlich jetzt noch schön, wenn Meta diese 167 Millionen irgendwie
an die IFF spenden würde oder an mich oder an irgendjemand anderes.
Also es ist ja schon ganz lustig, also gemessen an dem, wie viele Leute die
NSO-Group überwacht, ist es ja wirklich ein kleiner Fisch gegenüber Facebook.
Man müsste eigentlich sagen, dass das hier, hier geht halt der Überwachungsriese
gegen einen kleinen, unangenehmen Mitbewerber vor. So könnte man das auch betrachten.
Aber natürlich ist es schön, wenn solche Staatstrojaner-Hersteller gerichtlich
zur Verantwortung gezogen werden.
Aber 167 Millionen US-Dollar Strafe an Meta, um den Aufwand auszugleichen,
um diese Sicherheitslücken zu schließen.
Also da habe ich ja so ein bisschen meine Zweifel, ob es wirklich 167 Millionen
US-Dollar gekostet hat, diese Sicherheitslücke zu schließen.
Das war wahrscheinlich eher so eine Nachmittags-Session in der Security-Abteilung
mit nochmal einer Woche Review vielleicht.
Nein, ich glaube, du hast, also, nee, nee, das ist,
die halbe Million ist die Kosten for fixing the attack und die 167 Millionen sind Damage, Damages.
Ah, dann.
Also es ist umgekehrt, also die halbe, 444.719 US-Dollar Schadensersatz.
Ah, okay.
Und die 167 Millionen sind quasi Strafe. Das kann schon sein.
Dann habe ich das jetzt gerade andersrum hier aus den Notizen rausgelesen.
Ja, das kann sein, dass ich das da ein bisschen falsch oder missverständlich notiert habe.
Nee, dann ist das auch alles super. Dann bin ich da fein mit.
Ist in Ordnung. Nimmt der Tim mit.
Kann man schon mal einen Jingle für einsperren.
NSO meinte natürlich, das ist gar gar keine Straffe nötig.
Wir bleiben im Bereich der Überwachung. In der Schweiz gibt es jetzt einen Verordnungsentwurf.
Ähm,
Von der Regierung, also der Bundesrat und das eidgenössische Justiz- und Polizeidepartement
wollen quasi mit diesem Verordnungsentwurf die Internetüberwachung ausbauen.
Und das sieht folgendes vor.
Online-Dienste und Kommunikationsanbieter sowieso, aber eben auch Online-Dienste,
die mindestens 5000 User haben,
sollen Metadaten wie IP-Adressen und Portnummern sechs Monate auf Vorrat speichern.
Der Polizei und Geheimdiensten beim Entschlüsseln von Inhalten helfen müssen
und User identifizieren können.
Und diese müssen dann also einen Ausweis- oder eine Führerscheinkopie vorlegen
oder zumindest eine Telefonnummer angeben, damit du für die Telefonnummer den
Ausweis zeigen musst, SIM-Karten-Identifikationspflicht.
Dass du quasi am Ende jeden dieser Accounts einer Person zuordnen kannst,
sämtliche IP-Adressen und Portnummern über sechs Monate hast und die quasi,
sollte das verschlüsselt sein, sind die Anbieterinnen verpflichtet,
bei der Entschlüsselung zu helfen.
Das ist weitreichend.
Einmal alles ist das, ne?
Ja. Und das gilt also für Plattformen, wenn ich das bei dem Artikel von Adrien
Fichter bei republik.ch richtig gelesen habe,
insbesondere oder quasi für,
Abgeleitete Kommunikationsdienste, also Messaging und E-Mail,
Signal, WhatsApp und sowas.
Natürlich auch Threema, der Messenger aus der Schweiz.
Aber im Prinzip auch alles, wo du überhaupt Nachrichten schicken kannst.
Und damit wäre, ich weiß nicht, wo Schweizerinnen und Schweizer das machen,
aber wenn dein Dienst irgendwie so eine Direct-Messaging-Funktion hat,
dann fällst du da mit rein.
Dann müssen alle identifiziert werden.
Ja, spannend. Spannende Idee, wie man auf sowas heute noch kommt und natürlich,
also der andere, glaube ich, relativ bekannte Service aus der Schweiz neben
Threema ist Proton, also Proton Mail.
Die müssten also, Proton, Million und Prima müssten also umfassende Überwachungspflichten einführen.
Das wäre alles sehr äh,
also das würde ich erwarten, dass das, oder ich würde hoffen,
dass die Schweiz sich dagegen erfolgreich wehren kann. Das ist schon natürlich wirklich irre.
Zumal, darfst du ja auch nicht vergessen, das würde nicht nur für diese Schweizer Services,
gelten, sondern natürlich auch für die Big Tech, die dann quasi sich freuen
könnten, dass sie alle ihre Userinnen mit Ausweis und so weiter erfassen müssen.
Das ist wirklich irre.
Ich kenne mich ja nicht aus, weder in der Juristerei im Allgemeinen noch speziell in der Schweiz.
Aber wenn ich die Begriffe hier mir so anschaue, macht es auf mich ja auch den
Eindruck, als ob es auf der einen Seite das Bundesgesetz gibt zu dem Thema.
Und dass wir es hier sozusagen nur um eine Verordnung im Sinne von nicht EU-Verordnung,
was ja unmittelbares Gesetz bedeuten würde, sondern eher vielleicht so,
wie das in Deutschland auch ist, dass die Verordnung sozusagen definiert,
was das jetzt konkret bedeuten soll.
Also es ist nicht unbedingt Gesetzeslevel hat, sondern das Gesetz hier an der
Stelle, also das Bundesgesetz zur Überwachung des Post- und Fernmeldeverkehrs.
Ah ne, Quatsch. Jene zum, ja, also so deute ich das gerade, bin mir gerade nicht
ganz so sicher, aber die Kommentare werden uns korrigieren.
So oder so soll halt hier eine relativ umfangreiche, Überwachung vorgenommen
werden, wo quasi einmal alles drin ist.
Also alle müssen identifiziert werden, alle müssen mitmachen,
sowohl die Telekommunikations- also Fernmeldedienste-Anbieter heißt es hier,
also die, die sozusagen Infrastruktur betreiben, als auch die Abgeleiteten,
also alle App-Anbieter, alles sozusagen einmal alles.
Ja, und also ich würde sagen, liebe Schweiz, da müsst ihr also das wird eure,
Überwachungsgesamtrechnung, Aber, aber, oi, oi, oi, oi.
Danke.
Also ihr müsst da mal ein bisschen gucken. Wenn ihr da eine schlanke Linie halten wollt, dann ...
Das spüre ich.
Also natürlich gibt es massive Proteste dagegen.
Und unsere Freundinnen und Freunde bei der digitalen Gesellschaft Schweiz Jetzt
sind natürlich auch neben der Wirtschaft, die da natürlich auch gegen ist,
auf Trab, um das zu verhindern.
So, schauen wir mal in die USA. Da gab es eine interessante Entscheidung der
amerikanischen Gerichte in einem Fall, der schon etwas länger läuft und zwar
zwischen Apple und Epic.
Und die Geschichte...
Da müssen wir den kurz erinnern. Der geht jetzt auch über viele Jahre,
seit fünf Jahren oder so.
Und es ging los.
Hier kurz das zu rekonstruieren, weil wir... Epic hat dieses Spiel...
Fortnite.
Fortnite. Und das ist sehr beliebt und,
Die haben quasi Leute in der Fortnite-App motiviert, dafür zu zahlen,
auf einem anderen Wege als über Apple.
Ja, motiviert ist eine schöne Formulierung. Also sie haben einen,
also Fortnite war auf vielen Plattformen
verfügbar, also so auf allen Gaming-Plattformen, aber eben auch auf iOS.
Und dann haben sie halt auch angekündigt und das dann irgendwie auch gemacht.
Sie haben halt sozusagen ein Software-Update released in den App-Store.
Wo halt so eine externe Bezahlmöglichkeit vorgesehen war.
Und das war nun mal explizit von den App Store Rules von Apple verboten.
Das heißt, sie haben das so ganz bewusst gemacht, auch gar nicht groß irgendwie
versteckt, sondern haben einfach groß rumgetönt, so ja, wir machen das jetzt,
weil wir sind ja im Recht.
Woraufhin sie dann natürlich von Apple erstmal gebannt wurden,
das heißt die App ist dann verschwunden und war nicht mehr verfügbar.
Wobei das bedeutet ja immer nur, man kann sie nicht mehr neu runterladen.
Also wer auch immer sie quasi noch auf dem Device hatte, da lief sie dann auch schon.
Und soweit ich mich erinnere, hat es dieses Update auch tatsächlich in den Store
geschafft, war aber irgendwie hidden oder so.
Das bleibe ich mir jetzt nicht mehr so hundertprozentig sicher. Wie auch immer.
Dann hat Epic so total eskaliert und man merkte auch schon, in ihrem Verhalten,
dass sie jetzt nicht so total überrascht waren, was Apple denn jetzt auf einmal so hat.
Weil die hatten dann gleich so Videos und Kampagnenmaterial am Start,
was dann innerhalb kürzester Zeit das Internet erledigte, was halt dann irgendwie
großepig so in den Rebellenstatus hochgehoben hat.
Und das böse Apple will ja hier irgendwie Gaming verhindern und so weiter.
Naja, dann ging es halt zwangsläufig vor Gericht.
Und Apple meinte halt einfach nur, ihr habt hier gegen unsere Rules verstoßen
und Epic hat dann da so einen Generalangriff draus gemacht und im Prinzip infrage gestellt,
dass Apple halt überhaupt einen App Store so betreiben darf oder als einziger betreiben darf etc.
Am Ende hat Epic diese Klage weitgehend verloren also ich glaube von 10 Punkten
waren 9 quasi für Apple mit einer Ausnahme,
woraufhin Apple eigentlich gezwungen war, externe Bezahlung zu ermöglichen.
Und auch zu ermöglichen, dass Apps darauf hinweisen dürfen.
Weil das war so eine dieser Regeln, dass du eben nicht außerhalb,
ohne dass Apple daran Geld verdient, Geld einnehmen darfst für deine Apps in deinem Dings.
Damit wollen sie im Wesentlichen verhindern, dass diese ganzen virtuellen Käufe
in Games, so hier irgendwelche Goldmünzen,
damit du dein Spiel länger spielen kannst oder früher in irgendwelche Levels
kommst und so, das ist ja auch nochmal so eine ganz weirde Subindustrie,
wo unheimlich viel Geld verdient wird.
Und da wollte halt Apple halt auch weiterhin seinen 30-Prozent-Schnitt machen.
Und die ganzen Gamer wollen das natürlich nicht, weil das ist natürlich eine
Menge Holz, was dabei rüberkommt.
Dieser ganze Free-to-Play-Kram im Besonderen lebt ja quasi davon.
So hier, App ist erstmal kostenlos, aber wenn du dann halt erstmal alle richtig
süchtig gemacht hast, dann wollen sie da schneller vorankommen.
Oder halt auch so In-App-Purchases, dieser ganze Unsinn mit irgendwie Verkleidungen
kaufen und Dance-Moves und was weiß ich, was da alles noch im Angebot ist.
Naja, auf jeden Fall, Apple hat es dann aber erstmal weitgehend ausgesessen
und hat eigentlich gar nichts getan.
Und ist jetzt aber dazu verdonnert worden, das dann doch mal zu tun.
Und waren wohl auch ganz gut vorbereitet jetzt auf diese finale Entscheidung,
dass das eben auch sofort in Kraft trat.
Mit anderen Worten, jetzt ist es erlaubt, dass Apps in ihrer App selber darauf
hinweisen und auch verlinken dürfen ins Web,
dass es sozusagen die Möglichkeit gibt, bestimmte Käufe, die für den Content sind,
außerhalb des App-Stores jenseits der Bezahlmöglichkeiten, die Apple normalerweise
bietet, durchzuführen.
Und also Apple hat ja nicht nur diese Links verboten, sondern halt auch so Dinge
wie auch nur zu erwähnen, dass die Apps das nicht dürfen und so weiter.
Also selbst das wurde sozusagen unterbunden.
Ja, man muss da glaube ich wirklich sagen, und ich habe es nur in Teilen gesehen
und gelesen, das Gericht war da schon sehr unhappy,
weil das, was hier jetzt geurteilt wurde, ist das, was eben damals schon geurteilt wurde.
Und was Apple halt einfach maximal
mit allen möglichen Steinen in den Weg letztendlich nicht umgesetzt hat.
Und das Gericht hat jetzt gesagt, naja, passt auf, ihr habt einfach das Urteil
von damals nicht umgesetzt und entsprechend werdet ihr,
wird das jetzt hier quasi kriminell, was ihr macht.
Weil ihr ja quasi dem Urteil, was ich gesprochen habe, in maximal bösartiger
Lesart irgendwie versucht habt, irgendwie absolut nicht zu entsprechen.
Spannend. Auf der einen Seite, dass Apple das tut.
Natürlich kannst du dir vorstellen, dass irgendwelche Apple-Juristinnen und
Juristen alles natürlich so minimal auslegen für sich selber,
wie es geht und alles, was sie irgendwie meinen, was noch ginge,
irgendwie versuchen zu tun.
Aber einen guten Eindruck macht das nicht. Gleichzeitig, klar, die versuchen.
Potenzielle Milliardengewinne da zu schützen, die sie durch diese Praxis aufrechterhalten können.
Klar. Also vor allem die Auseinandersetzung mit Epic, die war ja dann sozusagen auch beyond Fortnite.
Also nachdem also Epic da nochmal einen draufgelegt hat und so einen dicken
Bugs gemacht hat und da quasi zu so einer allgemeinen Revolution aufgerufen hat,
hat ja Apple auch Epic komplett auch den Developer-Account gespielt.
Für ihre 3D-Engine gab es dann doch nochmal eine Ausnahme und so weiter,
aber im Wesentlichen ist Epic halt irgendwie komplett gebannt worden.
Und jetzt tut Epic natürlich wieder so, als wäre jetzt alles tutti und hat jetzt
irgendwie angekündigt, dass sie demnächst Fortnite wieder in den iOS-Appstore einstellen wollen.
Da gibt es allerdings noch überhaupt keine Anzeichen dafür, dass Apple das irgendwie
jetzt erlaubt, weil im Prinzip,
Die alte Entscheidung ja immer noch und das, was halt jetzt moniert wurde,
hat jetzt damit erstmal so nichts zu tun.
Das wird man sehen. Und was man natürlich jetzt auch sehen muss,
ist, das Ganze gilt natürlich nur für die USA. Das heißt, diese ganze Aufweichung
der Regeln, die jetzt Apple hat machen müssen, geht nur für den US App Store.
Sicherlich ein großer Teil ihres Marktes, aber es hat keine Auswirkungen auf
die EU oder auf den Rest der Welt.
Und ich finde das insofern auch jetzt mal ganz bemerkenswert,
weil eigentlich die US-Gerichtsbarkeit das macht, was eigentlich nötig wäre.
Nämlich mal konkret die Regeln in dem App Store von Apple selbst anzugehen,
weil die sind ja eigentlich das Problem.
Während die EU ja nur gesagt hat, ach, ja, also wenn das nicht so schön ist
da bei euch, dann machen wir halt einfach andere App-Stores.
Nur dass natürlich die Scharfkantigkeit so einer,
ich benutze jetzt eine andere Plattform, um meine Software zu kaufen,
auch wenn das irgendwie erlaubt ist,
relativ hoch ist, weil der technische Aufwand dafür sehr hoch ist und Apple
natürlich auch tausend Sachen wieder eingefallen sind,
wie es den Leuten so etwas verleiden kann mit ihrer Plattform-Fee und so weiter.
Da haben wir ja noch gerade die Auseinandersetzung mit der EU.
Ich fände es ja mal angemessener, konkret auf diese Bezahlregelung des App-Stores
selber zu schauen und dort zu reglementieren, weil dann könnte man sozusagen
unmittelbar die Dinge vielleicht verbessern.
Das wird sich zeigen. Also das war immer mein Reden.
Apple muss auf jeden Fall reguliert werden. Alle diese App-Stores müssen reguliert
werden mit sinnvollen Maßnahmen.
Aber halt in dem, was sie halt konkret machen und nicht dadurch,
dass man jetzt sagt, nö, dann bauen wir einfach nochmal komplett separate Infrastrukturen
auf, die nicht kommen, wie wir ja auch sehen.
Also dieses EU-Reglement gibt es irgendwie seit Anfang des Jahres.
Es gibt halt im Wesentlichen zwei alternative App-Stores, nämlich den von Epic,
den sie sozusagen out of spite machen und dann diesen anderen,
wo es im Wesentlichen nur einen,
so einen Retro-Emulator gibt, dessen Kosten aber wiederum von Epic getragen
werden, weil die sich irgendwie selber darüber gar nicht finanzieren können. Und das war's.
Und ich habe auch wenig Hoffnung, dass da noch sehr viel mehr kommen wird.
Also ein Riesenaufwand für nix.
Und es wird einfach mal Zeit, dass man sich konkret ausdenkt,
okay, wenn wir so einen monopolartigen oder wie auch immer man das nennen möchte,
ein Konstrukt haben mit so einem Gatekeeper zu einem Markt, der sozusagen in
sich ja nochmal ein großer Markt ist, weil es ja auch vollkommen klar ist,
du kannst heutzutage keine Software an den Start bringen.
Für die allermeiste Software gilt das zumindest, wenn du nicht auch irgendwie
eine App im App Store hast.
Und wenn Apple da halt Regeln macht, die quasi einen freien Markt gefährden.
Dann soll man doch auch direkt an diese Regeln rangehen selber und nicht sagen,
nee, wir müssen jetzt doch nochmal komplette, separate Ökosysteme aufmachen,
die dann ja auch nochmal alle irgendwie für sich nochmal reguliert werden müssen.
Also wir werden sehen, was das kommt. Ich hoffe, dass die EU sich da noch ein
bisschen was einfallen lässt, weil wenn die EU und USA da auch ein bisschen
eine gemeinsame Linie ziehen könnten, zugegebenermaßen ein bisschen schwierig,
aber dann könnte man eben auch Apple dazu bringen, weltweit hier entsprechende
Änderungen vorzunehmen.
Immerhin zeigt sich hier nun wirklich, dass das,
also ich glaube, wir beide stimmen
damit überein, dass der App Store insgesamt ein so großer Markt ist,
dass man den jetzt nicht mehr einfach nur den reinen Profitinteressen von Apple überlassen kann.
Auch wenn man argumentieren kann, dass sie natürlich viel tun,
um den Aufrecht zu erhalten und so weiter, aber wenn da halt derartige wirklich
Evil-Practices stattfinden.
Ich glaube, was Apple sich da auch zur Last legen lassen musste in dem Kontext
ist, sie ist ja bei bestimmten Erlauben, also Netflix zum Beispiel.
Traditionell, da erkennt Apple an, dass ihr Beitrag als iPhone eher nur ist,
da wird was mitge... Da wollen wir natürlich auch eine App haben,
mit der man da reingucken kann bei dem Netflix.
Und bei Epic haben sie eher gesagt, das ganze Fortnite, was ihr da schön gebastelt
habt, das gibt es ja alles nur wegen des iPhones.
Ja, also Netflix verhält sich da anders. Ich meine, das Interessante ist,
es gibt ja auch einzelne Ausnahmen für bestimmte App-Klassen.
Es gibt zum Beispiel so diese Reader-Apps, die sowas halt theoretisch dürften.
Davon wird verhältnismäßig wenig Gebrauch gemacht. Könnte man auch nochmal schauen, warum eigentlich.
Aber das ganze Bedarf einer Überarbeitung. Und es stimmt natürlich,
dass große Player, die auch für Apple wichtig sind, natürlich ein ganz anderes Gewicht haben.
Und das muss auch für kleinere gemacht werden.
Und generell finde ich, dass die EU-Regulierung vor allem eben für kleine Softwareanbieter
halt eigentlich nichts tut.
Weil niemand kann sich diese anderen App-Stores leisten.
Und das wäre einfach viel wichtiger, Dass man einfach sagt, okay,
kleine Anbieter, am Anfang zahlst du weniger und dann zahlst du vielleicht mehr,
wenn du es dir auch wirklich leisten kannst.
Solche Regelungen, auch so
Patreon-Modelle, also einfach andere Finanzierungsmodelle auch zuzulassen.
Da ist eigentlich eine Menge Musik drin, aber bisher hat da keiner Bereitschaft
gezeigt, mal die Instrumente aufzunehmen.
Apple hat außerdem zu einem beachtlichen Effekt am Stockmarket geführt.
Und zwar hat der Eddy Q, heißt der glaube ich, das ist der, der quasi den Services
Teil da irgendwie leitet von Apple.
Der hat sich zu den Milliarden geäußert,
die Google jedes Jahr an Apple zahlt, damit Google die voreingestellte Suchmaschine in Safari ist.
Richtig.
Und auch das hatten wir ja hier öfter diskutiert, was ist das denn jetzt mit
dieser Praxis und so und wir hatten das unter vielen Gesichtspunkten behandelt.
Einmal, dass diese Zahlung für den Browser Firefox im Prinzip die Finanzierung
ist, also weil Mozilla dieses Geld bekommt,
können sie überhaupt einen Mozilla Firefox entwickeln.
Und würde das nicht mehr kommen, dann droht dem ganzen Ding der Bankrott.
Gleichermaßen haben wir das behandelt und es wird hier gerade auch gerichtlich
behandelt, in diesem Kontext kam auch dieses Zitat, dass Google diese hohe Milliardenzahlung,
ich glaube 20 Milliarden oder was das ist,
nicht leistet, weil sie sagen, das ist es uns wert oder hier gibt es einen zweiten Bieter,
den wir nochmal um eine Milliarde überbieten müssen, um uns bei Apple positionieren zu können,
sondern dass sich der Eindruck aufdrängt, dass Google diese Zahlung leistet,
damit sich dort niemand anderes positionieren kann.
Und im Rahmen dieses Gerichtsverfahrens, da haben du und ich ja auch schon mal
ein bisschen drüber gestritten, aber im Rahmen dieses Gerichtsverfahrens sagte
jetzt der Eddy Cue, ja, müssen wir mal gucken.
Das mit diesem Google, das ist ja irgendwie auch nicht mehr so der,
vielleicht nicht mehr ganz so zukunftsweisend und wenn hier demnächst die Leute
sich daran gewöhnt haben,
dass sie bei AI-Systemen bessere Ergebnisse bekommen,
Da müssen wir natürlich auch mal überlegen, ob wir eventuell auf diese,
im Sinne unserer Kundinnen und Kunden, auf diese Milliardenzahlungen verzichten
und da was Vernünftiges anbieten müssen, damit unser iPhone weiterhin cool ist.
Diese Äußerung, würde ich sagen, ist auf mehrere Weisen was Besonderes.
Erstens, damit hat er, glaube ich, den Sargnagel geliefert, dass diese Zahlung
halt kartellrechtliches Problem ist, weil sie sich damit eben diese marktbeherrschende
Stellung sichern und nicht wirklich einen Wert kaufen.
Sie machen es einfach nur für andere schwer achievable, sich dort zu positionieren.
Aber zweitens ist dann natürlich auch der Google-Aktienkurs einfach mal um 8%
eingebrochen, weil klar war, ah, schau an,
Google ist auf dem Weg,
nicht mehr die beste Lösung zu sein und ist eventuell sogar schon so schlecht
im Vergleich zu anderen Innovationen,
die dieses Internet inzwischen herbeigeführt hat, dass Apple noch nicht mal
mehr sich für ein paar Milliarden erlauben kann,
die als Default in ihr System zu setzen, wenn sie weiterhin ihren Kundinnen
und Kunden die besten Geräte, die sie liefern können, liefern wollen.
Ja, es ist schwierig einzuschätzen, was jetzt die Motivation für diesen Kommentar war.
Ob das überhaupt so bewusst in die Welt gesetzt wurde oder eher nur so überinterpretiert wurde.
Ich bin mir da auch selber nicht so sicher. Ich denke mal, Google…,
ist jetzt nicht so, dass Google nichts drauf hätte in Bezug auf AI.
Es ist halt nur so, dass eben manche Suchmaschinenanbieter und in diesem Zusammenhang
wurde ja auch Perplexity zum Beispiel genannt,
sagen wir mal zumindest mehr Aufmerksamkeit erzeugt haben in der allgemeinen
Bevölkerung, als es jetzt andere Versuche wie DuckDuckGo oder so vorher getan haben.
Es gab ja schon immer alternative Suchmaschinen, aber die AI-Suchmaschinen selber.
Haben zumindest es geschafft, einen gewissen Marktanteil zu holen,
auch wenn das irgendwie nicht ansatzweise nennenswerte Anteile sind von Google.
Nur wir wissen ja, wie es ist im Tech-Markt, wenn sich eine Technologie erstmal
als ja, ich sag mal, so viral entwickelt.
Also dass Leute sagen so, um, das ist aber toll. Was weiß ich so,
wie das bei ChatGPT halt am Anfang auch war. Dass die Leute so, um, das ist aber cool.
Klar, dann kannst du nach einem Monat hinschauen und sagen so,
ja, das benutzt ja fast kaum einer, aber zwei, drei Monate später geht das so
dermaßen durch die Decke und ist dann halt auch unaufhaltsam,
dass es dann irgendwie auch absehbar ist,
dass der Wechsel dann auch unvermeidlich ist und dass er dann auch massiv ist.
Und das ist ja eigentlich immer so ein bisschen die Kunst, einen Tech-Markt
für diese Trends den richtigen Blick zu haben.
Was ist eigentlich das, was in zehn Jahren normal ist?
Jetzt haben wir 2025, wenn wir mal zurückblättern auf 2015, ich glaube,
weder du noch ich hätten in irgendeiner Form eine Wette abgeliefert, was sich im Hinblick auf.
Das, was wir heute AI und LLMs nennen, entwickeln würde.
Also was das für eine fundamentale Änderung von allem ist.
Und das ist ja genauso eine grundlegende Umschichtung des gesamten Tischmarkts,
wie es auch zum Beispiel durch das Smartphone geschah.
Wo also auf einmal Microsoft aus seiner alldominierenden Position rausgekickt
wurde mit einer Geschwindigkeit, wie das keiner vorher hätte erwägen können.
Und sicherlich befinden wir uns jetzt auch wieder in so einem Bereich,
wo irgendetwas wird den Durchbruch bringen.
Ob Google da allerdings keine Rolle drin spielen wird, das sehe ich noch nicht so ganz genau.
Absolut. Also es ist erstaunlich, also vielleicht noch ganz kurz,
weil es ja die ganze Zeit hier um Kartellrechten, marktdominierende Stellung und so weiter geht.
Muss man, denke ich, ist hier ein sehr guter Messwert von,
Google hat bis heute keine überzeugenden,
also keine ähnlich überzeugenden Produkte wie Perplexity oder Chatchipty,
es gibt dieses Google Gemini,
ja und manchmal, wenn man was googelt, sagt es auch, guck mal hier,
ich habe mal versucht, dir mit KI eine Antwort zu machen und so,
aber das ist weit hinter dem, was man in der Avantgarde dieser Innovation sieht. um,
Das ist auf verschiedene Stellen faszinierend, weil Google ja im Umgang mit
großen Datenmengen und auch in der Idee, diese großen Datenmengen,
mit denen umzugehen, um KIs zu trainieren und so weiter, am längsten tätig ist.
Und natürlich Google als nach wie vor marktbeherrschend das größte Kapital hat,
um erstens so etwas tatsächlich aus dem laufenden Betrieb zu bauen oder aus
dem laufenden Cashflow zu investieren, um so etwas zu bauen.
Zweitens aber natürlich auch, die Kohle hat potenziell, wenn da irgendein Konkurrent
überholt, den kaufen zu können. Und das ist das, was ich potenziell erwarten würde.
Entweder Google nimmt jetzt mal seine ganze Kohle und macht mal was damit und
entwickelt dann am Ende einfach mit noch viel mehr Geld ein noch viel besseres
Produkt, um dann seine marktbeherrschende Stellung weiter zu zementieren und zu nutzen.
Oder sie kaufen halt jetzt vielversprechende Konkurrenz früh auf.
Das wäre ja so die Wege, wie man so klug als großer Konzern agiert.
Ja, also ich denke, man darf Google an der Stelle auch nicht unterschätzen,
dieses Gemini-System und so weiter.
Das kann auch schon eine Menge und auch das Paper zum Transformer-Modell,
was ja eine ganze Menge ausgelöst hat.
Das Paper vom Transformer-Modell, super Paper, aber irgendwo sehe ich gerade
nicht, dass sie das umsetzen.
Also irgendwo wäre ich als Aktionär von Google, würde ich sagen,
schönes Paper, könnte er mal noch eins machen oder könnte er vielleicht was
daraus machen, was Geld bringt.
Ja, das ist richtig, dass es diese Vorbehalte gibt.
Ich sage ja nur, es kann aber auch genauso schnell sowas geben und dann sieht
das schon wieder ganz anders aus.
Also deswegen, da ist noch viel zu viel Bewegung und viel zu viel Dynamik in
diesem ganzen Markt, sowohl in dem Markt als auch in der Technologie.
Ohne Frage.
Also du siehst irgendwie, es ist zwei, drei Monate her, da haben wir dann irgendwie
über China und Deep Seek geredet und jetzt können die Amerikaner alle einpacken.
Dann kommt aber irgendwie Chat-GPT wieder mit dem nächsten Move raus,
mit dem neuen Bildergenerator, wo man dann irgendwie fassungslos davor steht
und sich denkt so, okay, alles, was wir uns in den letzten sechs Monaten beschwert
haben, ist jetzt schon wieder vom Tisch.
Also das kann alles sehr schnell gehen.
Ohne Frage, aber wie gesagt, hier der Fokus dieser Zahlungen,
die Google da leistet und ich glaube,
da ist dann schon wirklich dieser Tatbestand erfüllt, dass das zur Zementierung
der marktbeherrschenden Stellung stattfindet.
Ja, jetzt zeigt sich aber natürlich auch die finanzielle Abhängigkeit vor allem
von Mozilla an der Stelle.
Also ich meine, wenn bei Apple dann ein paar Milliarden weniger eingehen von
Google, dann mag das sicherlich auch irgendwie einen Impact haben,
aber ich denke mal, die kriegen im Zweifelsfall die Milliarden dann halt einfach von jemand anders.
Da bin ich mir noch nicht so ganz so sicher ob das bei Mozilla auch so der Fall
sein wird, weil wenn der Finanzchef schon warnt, dass sie irgendwie kurz vor
Bargrott stehen würden,
dann wird es halt gefährlich und das stellt natürlich auch die Frage inwiefern
wir überhaupt noch eine Competition haben werden in diesem Bereich wenn man mal,
das ehrlich betrachtet derzeit gibt es halt im Kern ein,
drei verschiedene Browser-Engines, die in irgendeiner Form das Web tragen.
Und der eine liegt im Wesentlichen bei Google, also die Engine unter Chrome, wie heißt die nochmal?
WebKit. Nee, WebKit ist das, was Apple macht.
Achso.
Chrome und Chromium basieren auf Gecko, keine Ahnung. ist auch egal.
Und Firefox hat noch seine eigene Engine. Es gibt dann noch ein paar kleinere Container hier und da.
Gecko, Chromium, Edge HTML und Presto sind die HTML Rendering Engines.
Und Gecko war jetzt aber bei Mozilla dann, glaube ich sogar.
Genau. Also Mozilla ist Gecko, Chrome, Chromium, Google und ja,
dann gibt es halt irgendwelche Zaubereien, ja.
Aber das sind quasi die,
die,
also der Teilcode, der das HTML und potenziell den DOM-Tree und dann auch Teiler
natürlich des JavaScripts, das dann wieder in dem DOM-Tree rumbastelt,
in irgendeiner Weise interpretiert und darstellt.
Blink. Blink ist die Engine unter Chrome.
Genau, bei Google Chrome Blink für HTML und V8 für JavaScript.
Deswegen wollte ich gerade V-Irgendwas sagen. Aber okay, also wie auch immer
das Problem ist, da gibt es relativ wenig.
Genau.
Es gibt relativ wenig Unterschiede, relativ wenig Konkurrenz auf diesem Markt.
Ja, okay.
So, dann gucken wir doch nochmal hier, was unsere Spezialexperten in den USA treiben.
Ja, wir erinnern uns an diese Signal-Affäre, wo der Mike Waltz irgendwie einen
Journalisten aus Versehen in seine Signal-Gruppe,
Huthi PC Small Group.
Principal Committee Small Group und so weiter da hatten wir alles hier besprochen,
hatten auch darüber gesprochen, dass es eben eine Sache ist,
ein abhörsicherer Messenger für die Masse zu sein, um sie vor dem Staat zu schützen.
Und eine andere Sache ist, ein abhörsicherer Messenger für eine Regierung zu sein.
Und das ist quasi für diese Classified Communication,
du dann üblicherweise doch ganz gut beraten bist, irgendwie geschlossene Nutzergruppen
und sonstiges zu haben und dass dich dann irgendwie die Spielzeuge für die Großen kaufst, für sowas.
Das heißt natürlich nicht, dass die nicht auch Signal nutzen können,
um mit ihrer Frau zu chatten.
Mike Walls hat dann auch, glaube ich, noch in irgendeine andere Gruppe dann
seine Frau reingeholt direkt oder so.
Auf jeden Fall wurde er jetzt mal dann doch langsam weggelobt zu den Vereinten Nationen. Und,
Unterschiedliche Interpretationen, ob das jetzt mit der Signal-Affäre zusammenhängt oder nicht.
Teile gehen davon aus, dass der Mike Walz vielleicht auch irgendwie den Donald
Trump ab und zu nochmal versucht hat, mit etwas wie Realitäten zu konfrontieren
und deswegen weggeschickt wird.
Keine Ahnung, was da los ist. Viel interessanter ist, dass der dann zufällig
in einem Foto gezeigt wurde, dass er, wie er Signal nutzt.
Und er war der US National Security Advisor.
Und dann wurde ein Foto von Reuters gemacht, wie er bei einem Meeting mit Donald
Trump auf sein Handy blickt.
Und da gibt es eine App, die sagt, zeig mal bitte deine TM-Signal-Pin.
Gib die mal bitte ein. Mit anderen
Worten, der benutzt einen anderen Signal-Client als den von Signal.
Nämlich eine App mit dem Namen TeleMessage TeleMessage Signal.
Die vermutlich also ich kannte sie nicht, aber die unter anderem wahrscheinlich
dem Zweck dienen sollte, Archivierungsmöglichkeiten zu bieten.
Weil, kleiner Exkurs, wenn regierungsrelevante Kommunikation.
Going Dark macht, dann ist das ein Problem.
Arne Semsrott hatte das, glaube ich, auch in seinem Vortrag beim Kongress dieses
Jahr nochmal behandelt, dass mitunter Ministerien sagen, ey,
wenn diese Frag den Staat Leute hier alles, was wir in die Akten schreiben, am Ende haben,
dann haben wir ja überhaupt gar keine Möglichkeit mehr hier offen miteinander mal zu reden.
Dann lasst uns mal lieber schön alles über Signal oder Wire oder weiß der Geier
machen. Irgendetwas, wo die nicht drauf zugreifen können.
Und das ist natürlich nicht in Ordnung für Regierungen.
Das ist aber auch potenziell in bestimmten Branchen nicht in Ordnung.
Also zum Beispiel irgendwie so Banker und Trader, die dürfen nicht solche,
die können nicht einfach irgendwelche oder in bestimmten Ländern zumindest nicht
einfach irgendwelche Disappearing Messages, Crypto-Messenger benutzen,
weil klar sein muss, wegen Insider-Trading und so weiter, dass jede Kommunikation,
die von dem beruflich relevant ist, in irgendeiner Weise erfasst wird.
Und diese Tele-Message scheint ein Anbieter zu sein, der sichere und compliant
Messaging-Solutions gibt, mit anderen Worten eine Archivfunktion für Messages,
WhatsApp und so weiter dann anbietet,
sodass Regierungsoffizielle auch auf diesen Kanälen kommunizieren können und
ihre Archivierungspflichten nicht verletzen.
Naja, dann kannte irgendwie eigentlich keiner, ja, dann wurde gesagt, okay krass,
was ist das denn für eine App, ja, dann wurde das halt irgendwie veröffentlicht,
dann hat es nicht lange gedauert, bis Leute auf der Webseite den Source-Code
gefunden haben und dann hat es nicht lange gedauert, bis die erste und die zweite
kritische Schwachstelle in dem ganzen System gefunden wurde,
und nach meinem Kenntnisstandes zu diesem Zeitpunkt wird das gar nicht mehr angeboten.
Ja, also die haben quasi, wenn du auf telemessage.com gehst,
haben die diesen Signal-Klon, der ist...
Hat jetzt nicht lange gedauert.
Übrigens einer der Gründe, auch das nur um die netzpolitische Dimension hier
auch wieder reinzubringen,
Signal wird mitunter auch dafür kritisiert, dass sie versuchen gegen solche
Third-Party-Messenger vorzugehen.
Können es natürlich nicht vollständig verhindern, dass sie zum Beispiel auch
sich bemühen, nicht zu föderieren mit anderen Lösungen, die ähnliche Krypto verwenden.
Und das ist aber eben einer der Gründe, weil sie eben sagen,
naja, wir machen hier bestimmte Sicherheitsversprechen und wenn Leute jetzt andere, ja,
in the middle Konstruktionen nutzen, dann können wir unsere Sicherheitsversprechen
denen gegenüber nicht mehr halten und deren Kommunikationspartnerinnen gegenüber.
Und so kommt es zu diesen Überlegungen, die in der Community teilweise auch
sehr stark kritisiert werden,
weil sich Signal hier natürlich einem föderierten Ansatz widersetzt.
Ja, lustig, lustig die Amis mit ihren Apps. TeleMessage Signal Archiver.
Ich frage mich, wie lange das System überhaupt schon in Betrieb ist dort.
Also ob jetzt das alles erst mit der Trump-Regierung eingeführt wurde und ob
das jetzt sozusagen die Antwort darauf war, dass sie vorher Signal benutzt haben.
Also mein Verständnis ist, dass wahrscheinlich schon länger für bestimmte,
Anwendungen quasi, sagen wir mal, approved war, um dieser Compliance-Anforderung zu entsprechen.
Also, dass es potenziell, was weiß ich, in weniger kritischen Bereichen der
Regierung gesagt wird, wenn ihr über Signal kommunizieren wollt,
dann nutzt das Ding, damit wir den Archivierungspflichten irgendwie nachkommen können.
Aber nicht unbedingt so wenn ihr eine geheime Chatgruppe zur Bombardierung des
Jemen machen wollt nutzt das Ding das ist quasi für non classified hast du nicht
gesehen Kommunikation irgendwann mal von irgendjemandem abgenommen wurde das war so mein,
der Verständnis beziehungsweise Interpretationsverdacht der hier im Raum stand
Da bin ich aber ein bisschen auf hearsay.
Das wird dann sicherlich auch nochmal rausfallen.
Das wird uns sicherlich auch ergänzt werden in den Kommentaren von Leuten,
die sich da noch tiefer mit auseinandergesetzt haben.
Apropos Leute, die sich tiefer mit Dingen auseinandersetzen.
Netzpolitik.org hat sich das Digitalministerium mal genauer angeschaut.
Welche Kompetenzen jetzt in diesem Digitalministerium zusammengeführt werden.
Wir hatten ja in der letzten Sendung, hatte ich ja anfangs so ein bisschen gescherzt,
dass da halt jeder so ein CEO aus der Online-Wirtschaft ohne Sozialisation und ohne Vorschäden,
in irgendwelchen Verwaltungen jetzt sich der Digitalisierung des Landes annähern soll, seine beiden,
wie nennt man denn so,
also rechte Hand, ich würde sagen, genau, rechte Hand ist Thomas Jatzombeck,
linke Hand ist Philipp Amthor.
Die schmutzige Hand.
Genau, die beiden, das sind ja jetzt seine seine,
Staatssekretäre. Er selbst ist übrigens parteilos. Das ist ja wirklich mal faszinierend.
Er hat noch nicht mal ein Parteibuch und kommt in diese Rolle als Minister.
Da kann ich mir schon mal vorstellen, dass war mindestens schon mal eine Stimme,
die Merz nicht bekommen hat. Wenn da Leute...
Naja, ich meine, er war im Wirtschaftsrat. Das zählt ja auch schon fast als Parteibuch.
So, außerdem tatsächlich fällt mir hier auf, die schreiben BDSM falsch,
da müssen wir noch den Buchstabendreher drin.
Das habe ich schon mehrfach gesehen.
Ja, das ist irgendwie, also das ist fehlerhaft.
Gut, also der Herr Minister Wilderberger war vorher der Geschäftsführer der
Mediasaturn Holding, hat ja seine beiden Staatssekretäre Jad Zombeck und Amthor.
Und außerdem kommt der Bundes-CIO Markus Richter, der ja vorher im Innenministerium war.
Dessen Amt geht jetzt im BMDS auf, wo er dann als Staatssekretär auch tätig sein wird.
Also, es schaut danach aus,
dass sich hier tatsächlich auch in dem Ressourcenzuschnitt etwas ändert und
Netzpolitik.org identifiziert hier drei Säulen.
Die erste Säule, also den Staat und die Verwaltung digitalisieren,
dann die Daten- und Digitalisierungspolitik und zuletzt dann auch die digitale Infrastruktur,
die hier jetzt hinkommen,
also die in diesem Ministerium stattfinden sollen.
Staatsmodernisierung, geht also alles, was vorher eigentlich in dem BMI war,
das digitale Verwaltung, Onlinezugangsgesetz, all das, zack, rüber ins BDSM.
Da gibt es dann unterschiedliche Themen, ja, es gibt zum Beispiel das ITZ-Bund das war beim,
Finanzministerium angedockt und das ist so ein bisschen die Rechenzentren des
Bundes, die kommen also jetzt auch dahin.
Informationstechnikzentrum heißt das, Bund Ja.
Und okay, dann hat das Digitalministerium also jetzt quasi auch den Betrieb
der digitalen Infrastruktur.
Dann damit auch die Hoheit über die IT-Ausgaben.
Das wäre also interessant. Das Haus hat also ein eigenes Budget und den Zustimmungsvorbehalt
für alle wesentlichen IT-Ausgaben der unmittelbaren Bundesverwaltung.
Das erinnert mich schon sehr stark an deinen Digitalvorbehalt.
Ja, mich auch. Ich möchte ein Sternchen dafür haben.
Wir grüßen unseren Hörer Fritze. Hat er gut zugehört bei uns.
Ja, ich meine, es ist auch erforderlich. Also ich denke, dieses ganze Ministerium
hätte auch keinen Sinn gemacht, wenn nicht zumindest ansatzweise sowas ist.
Wie scharf das Schwert ist, das wird man natürlich noch sehen.
Aber grundsätzlich haben sie jetzt
schon mal dafür gesorgt, dass dieser übergreifende Charakter, den das hat,
sich hier im Zuschnitt halbwegs abzuzeichnen scheint. mal zurückhalten, formulieren.
Es sind natürlich auch, wie gesagt, die haben es ja sehr genau angehört,
ein paar Sachen sind natürlich auch unklar, wie fügt sich jetzt am Ende das
BSI in diese Sache ein, was ist mit dem Projekt.
IT-Konsolidierung bunt, ja,
da wird also einiges noch ein bisschen sich einrütteln müssen,
aber ja, erstmal das machen die also jetzt.
Die zweite Säule, ist die Daten- und internationale Digitalpolitik.
Die waren natürlich vorher eigentlich eher bei dem BMDV, dem Bundesministerium
für Digitales und Verkehr, unter Volker Wissing.
Und setzt sich dann so ein bisschen mit den internationalen Auseinandersetzungen,
Also zum Beispiel die Positionierung zur Chatkontrolle,
die ja Deutschland nein immer noch war, wurde primär von dort auch getragen oder vorangetragen.
Anfangs gab es ja auch, wenn ich mich erinnere, so eine Rangelei zwischen Wissing und Fäser.
Gut, das liegt also jetzt hier. Das heißt KI-Verordnung.
Umsetzung der KI-Verordnung für Deutschland, zack, BMDS, BDSM,
jetzt mache ich das auch schon und derartiges, also irgendwie Digitalpolitik.
Und wenn man sich überlegt, dass der Mann aus der Wirtschaft kommt,
kann man sich vorstellen, dass die Umsetzung der KI-Verordnung in Deutschland
natürlich eher wirtschaftsfreundlich sein wird als grundrechtsfreundlich.
Und den Bereich der digitalen Infrastruktur, auch das ja etwas,
was wir in Deutschland bräuchten, geht also auch dorthin.
Und wir haben das Ziel, Etappenziel der EU, bis Ende des Jahrzehnts soll allen
Bürgerinnen gigabitfähige Leitungen und 5G-Mobilfunkverbindungen zur Verfügung stehen.
Da bin ich mal gespannt, wie sie das hinkriegen.
Damit wird er sich jetzt also auseinandersetzen was nicht für das Digitalministerium
eine Rolle spielen wird und das finde ich auch irgendwie einleuchtend zivile Drohnen und Flugtaxis,
werden sie also nicht machen das geht ins,
Wirtschaftsministerium.
Wo war denn das vorher es gab eine Zuständigkeit für Flugtaxis?
Das ist jetzt ein Witz von dir oder was?
Nö.
Also das sind die U-Spaces and Advanced Air Mobility.
Die waren vorher im BMDV und die wandern aber jetzt ins BMW,
ebenso wie Erdbeobachtung, Satellitennavigation und Galileo.
Wie gesagt, die waren halt vorher in dem Digital- und Verkehrsministerium und
wandern jetzt nicht mit darüber.
Insofern wird das gedeutet als verliert er.
Galileo wandert ins Wirtschaftsministerium?
Aha.
Interessant. BMW oder ist das jetzt Dorothee Bärs.
Ich versuche das gerade wenn ich BMW e-google komme ich auf BMW,
meinen Sie BMW nein ich meinte BMW e,
stattdessen suche nach BMW Bundesministerium für Wirtschaft und Klimaschutz BMW e.
Okay aber wir haben ja noch das Bundesministerium für Technologie und Forschung.
Ja, also okay, pass auf, das sind wirklich irgendwelche Kleinigkeiten,
also irgendwie Zuständigkeiten für Raumfahrt, ja, leuchtet ein,
das war halt vorher da, das kommt jetzt irgendwo anders hin,
zu Forschung, Technologie und Raumfahrt, deswegen heißt das Bundesministerium
für Forschung, Technologie und Raumfahrt und insgesamt Forschung,
also Innovations- und Technologiepolitik und so weiter ist auch nicht dort.
Aber es ist ja auch, also überrascht mich jetzt alles nicht.
Ist egal für das Digitalministerium, ich war jetzt nur gerade überrascht,
dass hier stand, dass Galileo jetzt zum Wirtschaftsministerium geht,
weil das geht bestimmt so dem Raumfahrt teil.
Das kann sein.
Ja.
Aber das waren jetzt also, ich glaube, das findet da nur Erwähnung,
weil das eben vorher bei dem BMDV war und jetzt nicht mit rüberzieht.
Ich glaube, das wird jetzt die Möglichkeiten und Einschränkungen und Aufgabenbereiche
des Digitalministers nur peripher beeinträchtigen.
Also diese Säulen machen ja erstmal Sinn. Daten und internationale Digitalpolitik,
digitale Infrastruktur und moderner Staat mit digitaler Verwaltung auf einer
Bundesebene angeordnet.
Und könnte sein, dass da jemand mal nachgedacht hat.
Könnte sogar sein, dass da vielleicht ein paar Leute Lehren gezogen haben aus
ihren Erfahrungen der letzten Jahre. Also vielleicht klappt das ja.
Also Stillstand der letzten Jahre primär noch.
Ja, also insgesamt klingt das erstmal alles nicht ganz falsch.
Da gibt es auf jeden Fall genug zusammengezogene Kompetenz, mit denen sie sich
jetzt erstmal rumschlagen können, Wenn das eine oder andere vielleicht auch
nochmal umziehen sollte, dann wird sich das vielleicht später noch ergeben,
aber so sind die wichtigen Dinge erstmal da.
Also Infrastruktur in Deutschland, dann natürlich das Umbauen des Staatswesens
auf digitale Dienste, das gehört natürlich dazu und da.
Ich bin vor allem gespannt, was jetzt dieser Zustimmungsvorbehalt am Ende wirklich
für Zähne entwickelt und natürlich auch,
wie sich das Ministerium jetzt in diesen politischen Fragen wie Chatkontrolle
oder wie soll denn überhaupt eine Wirtschaftsstruktur für unsere digitale Infrastruktur
aussehen, wie sie sich da verhalten.
Keine Ahnung, wie er sich da positioniert. Man kann halt sagen,
okay, ist ja wirtschaftsfreundlich, aber die Nähe zur Deutschen Telekom war
ja eigentlich eher immer so eine Staatsfreundlichkeit und nicht so sehr eine
Wirtschaftsfreundlichkeit.
Und vielleicht geht man hier mal andere Wege.
Man merkt schon, wir sind fast voller Hoffnung.
Ich würde in dem Kontext, noch kurz setzen, auch im Nachklapp zu unserer letzten
Sendung mit Bianca zur elektronischen Patientenakte,
noch zwei Nachbeobachtungen, weil da nämlich auch unter dem,
Keine Verantwortung nirgends von Daniel Leisegang, der Co-Chefredakteur neben
Anna Bieselli bei Netzpolitik.org,
der sich das auch nochmal anschaut und sagt so, wer ist jetzt hier eigentlich schuld?
Und übrigens möchte ich in dem Kontext nochmal kurz etwas zitieren,
weil ich die Freude hatte,
kürzlich in einem kleineren Kreise nochmal über diese EPA-Sache zu diskutieren
und in dem Kontext herausgefunden hatte,
dass das Passwort zum Schutz von Computersystemen 1962 am MIT erfunden wurde
und in den 80er Jahren wurden Krypto-Smartcards übrigens von Siemens,
damals noch Siemens, heute Infineon zum ersten Mal irgendwie erfunden und auch
das Konzept der Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung.
Drei fundamentale IT-Security-Entwicklungen, die ja auf die beim Schutz.
Des Zugriffs auf die elektronische Patientenakte verzichtet wurde.
Das habe ich nur noch mal in dem Kontext recherchieren dürfen und dachte, das teile ich mal hier.
Und jetzt würde sich ja durchaus die Frage stellen, wie kann das denn eigentlich
sein, dass in diesem Lande eine solche elektronische Patientenakte jemals an den Punkt kommt?
Warum hat niemand bei der Gematik jemals gesagt, pass mal auf,
hier gibt es so ein Paper aus den 80ern, wie man Zugangsschutz machen könnte.
Lass uns doch mal versuchen, ob wir auf diese Forschung vertrauen.
Und das kritisiert auch der Daniel hier, sagt also hier,
es ist ein fundamentaler architektonischer Fehler, BSI,
BFDI in irgendeiner Weise sagen, naja, wir haben ja schon gesagt,
dass das irgendwie nichts ist, aber gleichzeitig wurden wir ja gemäß dem 2023
verabschiedeten Digitalgesetz sind wir nicht mehr,
haben wir quasi keine Wirkungshoheit über die Gematik, Denn die Gematik musste
sich seit 2023 nur Festlegungen und Maßnahmen,
die die Fragen der Datensicherheit berühren.
Nicht treffen im Einvernehmen mit BSI und BFDI, sondern nur noch im Benehmen mit BSI und BFDI.
Also seit 1923 wurden quasi BSI und BFDI entmachtet, dort wirklich vielleicht
mal konkret reinzugrätschen.
Entsprechend sagt das BSI natürlich auch, naja okay, ist nicht unsere Verantwortung.
BFDI, der Alte, sagt ja schon, Leute, das könnt ihr so nicht machen.
Und Lauterbach zieht von dannen und die Gematik sagt, nee, das ist ja immer
noch höchste Standards, was einfach mal faktisch falsch ist.
Also es ist einfach nur Unsinn, das ist einfach nur Stoß.
Und irgendwie ist keiner schuld. Das haben die wirklich elegant gemacht.
Also wenn wir da nicht aufpassen mit dem Digitalministerium und vernünftigen
Zuschnitten, dann haben wir demnächst wieder jemanden, den man verantwortlich
machen kann, wenn irgendwas scheiße läuft. Das wäre gefährlich.
Also das sollte man eigentlich vermeiden, wenn man ein Imperium bauen möchte.
Wollte ich nur an der Stelle nochmal erwähnen. So, dann hätten wir noch zwei
Termine aus dem Freifunkumfeld, auf die wir hinweisen möchten.
Und zwar Ende Mai, das Wireless Community Weekend in Berlin auf der Seabase.
Also 30. Mai bis 1. Juni. Das ist das große Treffen der Freifunk-Communities.
Gibt es seit über 20 Jahren.
Seaways, guter Ort, wo man Grillen hacken kann und es gibt Vorträge und Workshops.
Und dann im Juni, 10. bis 16. Juni in Thüringen ist das Battle Mesh in seiner 17.
Iteration mit Camping. Das ist das internationale Treffen von Entwicklerinnen
und Netzaktivistinnen, die anfreien dezentralen WLAN-Netzwerken arbeiten.
Da wird dann neue Technik getestet, Wissen geteilt, neue Infrastruktur gemeinsam aufgebaut.
Und Würste und Klöße gibt es dann wahrscheinlich auch.
Beim Battle Mesh?
In Thüringen.
Ja, mal gucken.
Keine Ahnung.
Mal schauen.
Habe ich jetzt mal nur so reingeworfen.
Hast du mal so gesagt. Jetzt sitzen die Organisatorinnen da und sagen, scheiße.
Das war doch alles vegan hier. Macht halt Klöße.
Ja, aber damit haben wir jetzt auch darauf hingewiesen.
Und damit sind wir am Ende der Sendung angekommen.
Achso, eine Sache muss ich noch sagen. Wir haben es im Podcast ja jetzt gar nicht behandelt,
dass die AfD als rechtsextremistisch eingestuft wird vom Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz
und sich dagegen juristisch zur Wehr setzt, wie auch schon bei der Einstufung als Verdachtsfall.
Und dass das Bundesministerium jetzt so eine Stillhaltezusage gemacht hat.
Das heißt, sie sagen, sie lassen quasi das, was aus ihrer Einstufung nun folgt,
auch an Befugnissen, die sie selber dadurch erlangen, zur Bekämpfung der rechtsextremistischen
Zusammenrottung, die es dort gibt,
dass sie die zunächst nicht zur Anwendung bringen werden.
Und ich wollte das hier auch nochmal kurz in den Kontext setzen,
weil es da eine etwas missverständliche Headline bei Tagesschau.de gab,
die den Eindruck erweckte,
dass das Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz diese Einschätzung quasi zurücknimmt.
Und das ist nicht der Fall, sondern das wird jetzt gerichtlich geklärt und quasi
in Anerkennung der Wirkungsmacht und des Urteilsvermögens des Gerichtes,
sagt das Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz, alles klar, bis das gerichtlich geklärt ist.
Werden wir da jetzt zurückhalten mit umgehen mit dieser Einstufung.
Das ist das, was da jetzt passiert ist und das ist offenbar nicht ganz so ein riesiger Aufreger,
wie es auch für mich nach dem erstmaligen Lesen dieser Überschrift und laienhaften
Einschätzung der juristischen Bedeutung war.
Und weil ich das gestern verbreitet hatte und da auch dann vielfach korrigiert
wurde, wollte ich hier nochmal ganz kurz die Gelegenheit oder ja korrigiert
und ins rechte Licht gerückt wurde, wollte ich hier nochmal die Gelegenheit dieser,
Ergänzung und inhaltlichen Richtigstellung gerade Rückung nutzen.
Alright. Aber jetzt sind wir am Ende der Sendung?
Jetzt sind wir am Ende der Sendung.
Dritter Anlauf. Da hat sich gerade noch was reingeschlichen. Kann ja mal passieren.
Jo Leute, das war's und hören wir uns nächste Woche wieder oder so.
So machen wir das.
Bis bald. Tschüss.
Ciao, ciao.